[Música]
direitinho acho que sim é bom
primeiro de tudo a essa oportunidade o
convite era pó e aproveitar a equipe só
pelo impulso ontem um discurso muito bem
delineado toda vez que eu faço uma coisa
assim
queria pegar um curso quem é que levanta
um favor que me conhece já consumiu
algum conteúdo meu na internet
obrigado mãe não é brincadeira não é
minha mãe de verdade está aqui na frente
inclusive inclusive aproveitar o momento
se falou tanto de mãe eu acho que 99%
dos palestrantes subiram em cima tocaram
no assunto mãe de alguma maneira então
queria usar a minha mãe como bode
espiatório inclusive pedir uma salva de
palmas a todas as mães aí é mais bacana
então desde o pará pode estender o
convite pra mim eu refleti muito sobre o
momento de estar aqui em cima é refletir
muito de várias formas a primeira delas
entender não consegui o meu papel aqui
no meio dessa grade de palestrantes
extremamente capacitados expoentes
dentro do mercado onde eu poderia
agregar desproporcionalmente num evento
como esse é porque toda vez que eu tô em
cima de um palco como esse e hoje em dia
graças a deus tem sido cada vez mais uma
constante pra mim e 80 preocupado em
puxar uma agenda própria minha
o meu único objetivo aqui em cima
entender por que vocês estariam sentados
num evento desse e tentar fazer a
engenharia reversa do que eu tenho que
falar em cima para entregar algum valor
para vocês
então pensando um pouco nisso eu sou um
cara que acredita em poucas coisas eu
tenho poucos países centrais
a minha vida então eu fui confrontado
com o desafio de que era falar de coisas
nas quais eu sou extremamente
confortável de falar e ao mesmo tempo
gerar valor para vocês eu acredito que
eu tenha encontrado uma interceção
bastante interessante e para falar um
pouco disso eu acho que de certa forma
isso se entrelaça com a minha história
tenho 27 anos extremamente novo é
atualmente o senhor da guerra mídia
agência publicidade mas eu acho que
falar isso é um pouco raso e não
constrói o contexto correto pra gente
enganando os outros temas porque como
garçom me falou na partida anterior o
motivo de eu estar aqui em cima
é passar pelo assim pela minha
trajetória ao longo dos últimos quatro
anos extremamente novo mas agora já é o
meu terceiro negócio é o meu terceiro
empreendimento e nos últimos quatro anos
o fato é que eu levei esse essas três
empresas de um faturamento de 3 milhões
ao ano para 20 milhões este ano e 100%
disso nas costas da internet
então eu acho que é aí que eu queria
criar uma interceção positiva e gerar
valor para vocês
tentando ea maneira que eu estruturei
essa conversa daquela passa por duas
coisas que acredita serem fundamentais
para entender como se faz isso no ano de
2018 que a oportunidade é essa que eu
tanto fala que ensine a primeira parte
da conversa passa por e tentar moldar
uma em sete de vocês para que vocês
possam entender do que eu tô falando e
com os olhares um pouco diferente ea
segunda parte eu queria entrar nas
táticas e estratégias específicas que
qualquer um pode usar para alcançar um
resultado similar manhã então então na
primeira parte é eu acredito
profundamente que em 2018 todo mundo
todo mundo sem exceção do sac necessário
incluindo eu não tem idéia do tamanho do
fenômeno sócio cultural e econômico que
é a internet
estamos todos eu inclusive um dos
maiores propulsores do discurso pela
internet do brasil atualmente todos nós
aqui estamos subvalorizando o tamanho
dessa oportunidade
isso tem um motivo muito claro é muito
complicado muito complicado você
analisar de uma maneira prática algum
evento dessa magnitude quando você está
no olho do furacão e todos nós aqui
estamos no olho também no centro do
furacão
então pensando nisso eu vou tentar
trazer as lentes um pouco para fora
inclusive falando coisas aqui que talvez
sejam totalmente a lei que vocês nunca
tenha ouvido como por exemplo eu
acredito profundamente com toda a minha
crença que em 2018
nós fomos se board e assim isso pode não
ter se materializado daquela maneira
como os filmes saifi previram um braço
mecânico uma cpu em vez do cérebro isso
não aconteceu mas o fato é que
esse aparelho aqui que está no máximo um
braço de distância de todo mundo aqui
nessa sala aumentou exponencialmente a
nossa capacidade analítica nossa memória
da nossa capacidade de influenciar as
pessoas
nossa capacidade de se relacionar enfim
tudo e aí eu acho que isso entra num
segundo ponto que talvez alguns de vocês
à primeira vista até discordem de mim
mas que eu já realizei eu tenho certeza
que todo mundo aqui vai realizar ao
longo dos próximos anos
que é isso daqui que nós estamos vivendo
hoje esse tete a tete aqui essa
influência pessoal um-para-um humana em
2018 e talvez até nos últimos anos
isso aqui se tornou secundário e
secundário no que tange eu queria fazer
um desafio vocês pra vocês voltarem na
mente de vocês em e tentar enxergar se
ao longo do último ano vocês foram mais
influenciados em ambientes assim toda a
tarde aqui dentro vocês formaram mais
opinião em ambientes assim touch ou aqui
dentro vocês consumiram mais informação
e moldaram os valores e as crenças e
mudaram de idéia por causa disso daqui
ou por causa de uma conversa que vocês
tiveram alguém três são uma prova disso
tanto aqui como nos estados unidos há
dois anos atrás
então pode parecer bizarro quando a
gente põe que isso aqui se tornou
secundário mas é real
os seres humanos em 2018 estão vivendo
através desse aparelho e eu entendo que
isso possa parecer negativo de alguma
forma e é aí que eu tenho quase que a
obrigação aqui em cima de mudar um pouco
essa narrativa porque eu sou
extremamente otimista com isso eu sei
que talvez alguns de vocês tenham tido
seus negócios transformados como um dos
palestrantes falou há pouco aqui quanto
lá em cima que o business do livro
talvez não tivesse mais aderência
preciso navegar no entanto talvez outras
pessoas não tenham conseguido eu entendo
quando alguém vai jantar e ver um casal
jantando e os dois no smartphone no
instagram e vai estar conversando você
tem um sentimento negativo
a partir daquilo eu entendo quando quem
tem filhos aqui em vez do filho e jogar
bola na rua está assistindo tweet vendo
ninja jogar forte night 3 horas da manhã
em vez de sá
jogando o peão soltando pipa eu entendo
que talvez as pessoas tenham sentimentos
negativos a respeito disso mas isso não
é negativo isso só é diferente
o grande lance é que o ser humano odeia
mudança e evolução deixou fazer mais uma
pergunta às pessoas aqui quem é que
gosta de mudanças de evolução levantaram
bem alto aqui pra mim não tira você
gosta das mudanças de evolução que caem
bem pra você a mudança e evolução que
não dá certo você chama de problema e
você reclama dele todos os dias então os
seres humanos não gostam de mudanças é
fundamental a gente cresceu valorizam o
outro estilo de vida valorizando outra
forma de fazer as coisas e quando a
gente olha para esse novo ecossistema
que mudou sim muito rápido nos últimos
dez anos a gente tende a olhar com um
olhar de desdém a gente tem de olhar com
o preconceito mas isso não é o seu filho
tá jogando videogame vai estar jogando
bola não pior é diferente e é aí que se
cria oportunidade pelo fato dos seres
humanos o diário a mudança é que se dá a
oportunidade massiva que a gente tem na
frente da gente hoje em dia eu não vou
ficar jogando esse termo oportunidade
oportunidade oportunidades em palpa isso
atrás de alguma coisa o grande lance é
que em 2018
a internet cortou todas as barreiras
para alguém que queria que o que quer
queria ou queira começar não ia a
internet é um intermediário você não tem
mais um gueto equipe porque te impeça de
fazer o que você quer
qualquer pessoa com acesso à internet e
um negócio desse aqui que você pode
parcelar em 12 vezes sem juros não em
qualquer loja de consumo têm a porta
para o mundo não tem mais ninguém
impedindo de fazer o que você queira
fazer você tá um conteúdo de um
relacionamento que pode abrir uma porta
você tá uma mensagem de um
relacionamento que pode abrir a porta a
barreira de entrada sumiu
vou contar um caso engraçado aqui 14
taj lounge uma das dez empresas a gente
contrata um software do linkedin que
permite você não dá a mensagem para
qualquer pessoa é que tivesse dentro da
rede e eu
fascinado com aquela e no primeiro dia
mandei uma mensagem para obama
e assim é óbvio que ele não respondeu
mas só o fato de que essa possibilidade
existe eu acho que exemplifica o tamanho
da oportunidade que existe na internet
então tendo de alguma forma que tentado
ajustar o discurso ea forma com que as
pessoas estão olhando pra esses
movimentos sócio cultural massivo eu
fecho a primeira parte é e começa a
entrar na segunda na segunda metade da
conversa é tentar desmistificar um pouco
desses termos complexos que todo mundo o
uso para explicar o que o digital que eu
sou show como funciona como acontece eu
tenho certeza que existe confusão e
acerca desse tema ea maneira que eu vou
fazer o break daum disso é bastante
simples tem duas partes
eu queria que imaginassem é como se
fosse um jogo e pra você jogar qualquer
jogo você precisa primeiro entender as
regras e no caso do digital não são as
regras é a regra
então esse é o número um eo número dois
é entender quais são as peças que formam
esse quebra cabeça
então voltando aí essa regra que
regressa e a regra do jogo não sou chio
digital é uma só e ela conecta desde o
estagiário da unisuam está aqui fazendo
um site rosso um job aqui enquanto os
mega empresários que passaram por esse
palco quando moleque que está começando
a carreira
uma regra conecta todo mundo que está
aqui que é a atenção das pessoas
antes você pode me dizer um bom seu
produto é o com folga o seu serviço é o
com um maravilhoso vai ser se eu
contratar o seu serviço ou se eu puder
te dá ouvido ou qualquer pessoa que não
eu não
você precisa da atenção das pessoas isso
não é novo não é de 2018 é ponto digital
já era verdade há dois mil anos atrás
qualquer impacto que você queira
promover uma pessoa você precisa da
atenção dela
o grande lance é que a tensão está
migrando de um lugar antes
para um lugar novo e aí as pessoas se
confundem
toda vez que você tem uma mudança dessa
natureza as pessoas se confundem e a
atenção neste momento está migrando de
tudo o que é o fone quando a gente já
faltou aqui que isso aqui se tornou
secundário para o ambiente digital e
dentro do ambiente digital
obviamente o placar
e aqui dentro para as 7 11 plataformas
que são quase que o s ok o sistema
operacional da internet que são os
brinquedinhos da vida está grande
facebook whatsapp twitter youtube e
unemat
essas plataformas são o que detém a
atenção das pessoas em 2018
superinteressante enxergar e de vez em
quando a confusão que as pessoas fazem
acerca dessas plataformas porque elas em
si também são bichos totalmente
diferente
o seu no inset quando você está dentro
do instagram consumindo alguma
informação é totalmente diferente do seu
padrão de consumo como consumidor
quando você está no youtube e quando
você está no linkedin cada uma dessas
plataformas têm um contexto de absorção
de informação totalmente diferente
então não é só você reconhecer a atenção
é você adaptar o que você quer fazer um
modelo de consumo que a pessoa está
naquele momento isso é a regra do jogo
atual e como é que você capta a atenção
das pessoas no ambiente que é totalmente
pulverizado e conturbado como isso aqui
foi onde você onde todo mundo aqui tem
uma rede social segue no mínimo e
quinhentas pessoas mil pessoas cada uma
porta duas três fotos por semana e isso
dá uma quantidade de 1.500 conteúdos por
semana que teoricamente é humanamente
possível e você consumir tudo como é que
você ganha como é que você chama a
atenção dentro desse ecossistema e aí
que a gente entra na segunda parte que
são as peças que formam esse quebra
cabeça ea primeira peça é conteúdo
a segunda peça é distribuição e você
pode usar vários nomes e pode chamar de
criativo de mídia se pode chamar o que
você quiser mas é conteúdo ea peça da
distribuição e nenhuma delas pode ser
ignorada
e quando eu falo de conteúdo muito em
cima do que o garçom me falou por
exemplo conteúdo dentro de si
ecossistemas não pode ser alguma coisa e
go está da mesma forma que você pra
fazer networking você precisa dar sem
esperança de receber a maneira que você
faz isso aqui funcionar é quando você
produz alguma coisa que não tem um
caráter de vendas
sou chorão mídia é seios e venda via
branding em relacionamento e na hora que
você entende isso e você começa a
produzir o tipo de conteúdo correto você
tem alguma chance de vencer dentro desse
ecossistema e é fascinante para mim como
assim social da agência mais fácil
comercial heitor tempo todo na frente de
clientes promovendo o as nossas pautas o
que a gente quer fazer e eu escuto dia
após dia as pessoas falarem que me
social não vende mas está no náutico o
fundador da maior instituição de
internet atualmente
foi chamado para depor na frente do
congresso de tão poderosa que a
ferramenta e aí vem alguém falar que não
dá pra vender ali dentro
então a primeira coisa é você entender
que conteúdo é a porta de entrada mais
conteúdo sozinho não faz milagre você
precisa de distribuição porque inclusive
eu tenho uma tese que é o melhor livro
já escrito a melhor música já composta
nunca foi ouvido por ninguém nesta sala
provavelmente foi escrito por uma
senhora na china que era viúva eo e um
pergaminho morreu com ela ou a música
por um indiano no interior da índia que
ninguém nunca escutou e esses conteúdos
não ganharam distribuição ea
distribuição se o conteúdo permite você
chamar a atenção das pessoas
a distribuição permite você promoveu o
impacto que você e qualquer um quer
dentro do seu negócio e falando de
distribuição
a gente vive uma época em termos de
sou show ebs patrocinados compra de
mídia dentro das plataformas sociais é
maior cabe trajem de todos os tempos
a capacidade de segmentação e opções de
estratégia que você pode montar e denso
são simplesmente sem precedente e aí
você fecha aponta da distribuição
mais uma vez eu reconheço que mesmo
assim mesmo com essas coisas ainda tem
gente que vai lá e aí eu já antecipa
alguns problemas do porque você vai você
vai errar porque você vai votar o seu
estagiário para fazer você vai dizer que
valoriza mas na verdade você não
valoriza tanto assim o seu estágio e vai
colocar um estagiário para fazer o
trabalho que no meu caso sou eu faço por
exemplo uma empresa ou você vai produzir
um conteúdo de merda desculpa palavra
com caráter vendedor você vai ser aquele
cara que fazendo analogia pede a garota
em casamento no primeiro date e não vai
entender que seu filme é uma ferramenta
dia que você primeiro precisa criar um
relacionamento então tempo acabando
tentar dar uma acelerada mas esses são
os erros mais comuns
então se eu pudesse passar uma última
mensagem aqui em cima pra vocês que
talvez criar um senso de urgência para
vocês fazerem alguma coisa a respeito
disso é entenda que essa oportunidade é
fêmea e ela é efêmera porque todas as
plataformas em cima das quais a gente 3
da atenção hoje em dia são movidas por
dinâmicas de oferta e demanda e pra eu
como economista é muito fácil pra mim me
relacionar com o sistema mas eu talvez
tenha que explicar para um outro aqui
mas basicamente um lugar que é regido
por dinâmicas de oferta e demanda
implica que quanto mais e no caso das
plataformas sociais quanto mais
anunciantes de pessoas produzindo
conteúdo ali dentro de um dado o nível
de olhares
essa dinâmica simplesmente para de
funcionar
quanto mais anunciantes entrarem nessas
plataformas ao longo dos próximos anos
quanto mais pessoas passarem a produzir
mais conteúdo essa curva não fica tão
interessante e alguém hoje que talvez
promova o resultado consolidou pagando
50 centavos a 1 real uns 50 esse jogo
não fica mais tão divertido hora que
você tiver que pagar 150 para promover o
mesmo resultado então entenda que essa
oportunidade é efêmera e sim dentro de
todos os rostos aqui nesse auditório eu
não tenho a pretensão de mudar a cabeça
de todo mundo gostaria talvez o impacto
a uma pessoa
uma pessoa que pegasse isso aqui fosse
fazer alguma coisa então se eu pudesse
deixar
um pedido de coração eu implorar ia para
que um de vocês produzir-se um texto
mais um post é mais uma foto mais um
vídeo a mais um conteúdo a mãe porque eu
sei que fez toda a diferença na minha
vida e eu tenho certeza que pode fazer
de você também
obrigado
[Aplausos]